ранок схід сонця остріл щойно закінчився
до противника метрів 300 а Україна така
гарна навіть тут
ми часто не помічаємо важливого в
буденних
речах поки Росія не почала війну ми не
відчували ціни
Миру поки не поширилася
пандемія побажання здоров'я лунали наче
потерті слова і навіть Великдень часто
густо зводять до яєць паскі ковбаски
багато хто втрачає віру в своїх
ближніх в майбутнє країни саміх
себе
Ми прийшли до свята свят через
випробування через війну і пандемію
через негаразди і несправедливості і не
піддалися на шантаж агресора і не
панікували через ковід ми чесно
працювали допомагали лікарям лікарням
ворим соціально
незахищеним як християни віримо що
Господь вказав нам дорогу до спасіння А
як українці знаємо що ця дорога пролягає
через любов до свого народа готовність
захищати рідну країну і разом творити її
майбутнє наша віра разом з Надією і
любов'ю вчать нас
милосерддю небайдужості і готовності
відгукнутися на біду водночас зміцнюють
нас у рішучості і
непохітності і не існує такої сили яка б
змусила нас звернутись зі шляху
праведного милістю божою все в нас буде
добре і буде
мир Отже Вітаю всіх вірних православної
церкви України яка вже третій Великдень
зустрічає як Українська незалежна церква
Поздоровляю православних інших церков
щирі вітання вірним нашої Української
греко-католицької церкви протестантським
громадам країни я вітаю всіх християн
всіх українців для кого Великдень
справді Великий день все в нас буде
Добре
обов'язково Христос
[музика]
воскрес